we're going to play our best game of the
year i mean this is a tough opponent all
year you know we're playing a team
that's
uh very talented they make it to this
point for a reason and we do everything
we do to to get the win i mean this is a
football team that's been playing really
well good on offense i got a very good
defense good front been very healthy
um
it's going to be a very tough tough game
yeah i mean you're going to hear that
from tom brady almost no matter what
right that's that's that's how he does
business he's going to build up the
opponent internally i'm sure he probably
feels pretty good about this matchup but
it's not the same all-star team that tom
brady sort of as
gm and quarterback had built there's no
antonio brown there's no chris godwin
there's going to be some new looking
weapons if they're going to go do this
thing how do you feel right now what's
your temperature on the tampa bay
buccaneers heading into the playoffs
i feel good i got tom brady if i'm in
tampa bay i feel good i still have tom
brady think about it it wasn't like tom
brady was thrown to all pro and hall of
fame receivers when he was winning
championships in 2001 2003 2004
back-to-back championships it wasn't
like he was thrown to hall of famers and
you know guys like that he was throwing
to david givens dion branch david patton
and those type of guys and daniel graham
was our tight end these guys aren't
going to be in a hall of fame they're
really good football players they're
unselfish they do everything they can
for the team so tom is going to be very
comfortable with those other guys here
they're going to be a level of
frustration at times but the most
important thing tampa has to do is not
get dominated like they got dominated on
the line of scrimmage against the new
orleans saints and the philadelphia
eagles they have those pass rushers
they're deep they can rotate guys from
the inside from the outside so that's
going to be the tell of the game can
philadelphia put pressure on tom brady
and hit him and get him off his mark and
make him uncomfortable jack
that's a good point we've seen that
eagles front give him issues in the past
man they stole a super bowl from him
with that exact formula
i don't know if it's quite to that level
but they still got a whole bunch of
those players right you know scotty
miller that's the same player that's one
of those young receivers one of those
lesser-known receivers referred to
remember against the packers in the nfc
championship game he caught that
touchdown right before halftime big
reason why they going to win this game
and you know i think tom has enough time
here you know losing a b he was losing
got when there's been enough time for
him to realize i need to start repping
out with these young guys with these
inexperienced guys and once he gets
those reps that's when it usually starts
to happen let's hear from bruce arians
here's head coach on talking his
quarterback potential mvp chances here's
what he had to say
bruce
uh make this succinct case for your
quarterback as uh as the mvp of this
league this season
i think if if he doesn't get it it's a
travesty
i mean
most completions ever
5 000 yards touchdowns the whole the
whole nine yards i mean i mean to me
it's not even it's not even a close race
a little biases right now but i'm gonna
tell you this tom brady was fantastic
and that's my dude right that's my dude
and he played unbelievable this year but
nobody played better than aaron rodgers
i got we got a chance to be up close and
personal and watch aaron rodgers and
that magic and all the different
injuries on the offensive line him
playing with a hurt big toe and nobody
was better than aaron rodgers flat out
aaron rodgers was the man i don't care
about records i don't care about numbers
completions at the end of the day when i
saw aaron rodgers play i said this is
the best this is the best player in the
national football league nobody can do
the things that he does
the way he does it and tom brady is my
dude he's in a close second but aaron
rodgers should be the most valuable
player in this league
yeah i don't think there's any question
i i am all over the aaron rodgers train
on this one i mean he threw those you
look at his stats man he has you know
four interceptions two of those came
that first week of the the season when
he's still coming back from hawaii mode
and vacation mode and he really like
basically skipped the preseason and just
goes out there and chucks the saints a
couple picks at week one like the rest
of the year he was damn near perfect man
i mean this was this this season for
mayor rodgers i have no doubt that he's
the mvp as well let's get you to this
next matchup for wild card weekend san
francisco 49ers they're headed into
dallas first thought that comes to mind
when you think about that game
um
san francisco you said yeah san
francisco against dallas uh once again
it goes back to jimmy g i think it goes
back to jimmy g he's gonna have to deal
with this pass rush i know kyle shanahan
he's gonna do all that run and all that
motion and all the misdirection and
things like that but at the end of the
day man when the cowboys when they're
focused when they're healthy when
they're honed in and they're focused on
football and not all the other crap
that's going on this is a very very good
football team we're gonna see exactly if
mike mccarthy can have his team ready
this is one of the most talented teams
that i've ever seen from the dallas
cowboys both on offense and defense you
got the quarterback you won tyron smith
he's going to be back one one one change
man when i watch zeke zeke is out
average he's just an average running
back man he looks slow
um i think it was last week when they
started putting those other running
backs in you could just see the
difference in speed the difference in
quickness the difference in explosive
plays zeke is not that guy you need to
put tony pollard give him more
opportunities to carry that that the
ball on the offensive side of the ball
and i just i don't i don't like what i
see from zeke
yeah he still gets those ace
responsibilities as the number one back
probably more so based on his resume his
career resume than based on what's
happening this season because when tony
pollard carries the football he is so
much faster and more explosive runs
harder and zeke looks like he's got a
knee injury that's honestly what he
looks like to me i like the cowboys in
that game though i really do i think
that cowboys defense overwhelms in a lot
of ways what jimmy garoppolo is trying
to do throwing the ball we've seen those
those three pass rushers with lawrence
randy gregory micah parsons that's about
as good of a trio as you're going to
find i think that's a cowboys win i'm
more nervous about the cowboys playing a
team like the cardinals but that may be
down the line let's get to arizona
arizona they're going to have to play
the rams so these are two teams here
arizona has won in la la has won in
arizona round three upcoming how do you
see it
wow kyla murray is
he's incredible it really hasn't been
the same since deandre hopkins is gone
it's he's still trying to get a feel but
to me i like arizona's defense i think
they have a bunch of really good
athletes they got guys they can get
after you and i like vance joseph
aggressive approach he's gonna blitz
he's gonna you know he's gonna and you
know he's gonna get after matthew
stafford and that's what you have to do
you have to pressure matthew stafford
you know um of course
cooper cup double team him in a
particular situations and see if odell
beckham see if those other guys can
really step up and make the plays but if
if i'm arizona i'm vance joseph there's
no way i'm allowing cooper cup to
destroy me this game he's not catching
10 or 12 passes for 150 yards that's not
going to be the case i'm double teaming
him i'm taking him out the game
it's a damn hard matchup man that's a
damn hard matchup if you're sean mcvay
in year one where you master planned
this whole thing to bring stafford in
and there's so much super bowl
expectation right now and it's almost
super bowl or bust with the way that
they put this team together and to have
to go play the cardinals they're
bringing back jj watt they have been
undefeated this year undefeated with j.j
watt god that defense already talented
without him but if he comes back and can
just give him something that's going to
be a scary sight
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports